à l'image des beatles
edith piaf charles aznavour johnny
hallyday nombreux sont ceux à s'être
produit pour la première fois en france
sur la scène du cirano mais le cinéma a
perdu de nombreux spectateurs des
entrées pratiquement divisé par deux
depuis une vingtaine d'années pour
préserver ce lieu mythique la ville de
versailles travaillent en collaboration
avec ugc le but resterait entièrement la
salle d' historique
c'est un projet très important pour nous
parce que c'est un cinéma au centre
ville et vous savez aujourd'hui on parle
beaucoup la désertification des
centres-villes et pour nous depuis dix
ans que je suis maire c'est vraiment
avec mon équipe
un combat c'est soutenir à l'activité de
nos commerçants nos mille six cents
commerçants qui reste encore en
centre-ville de versailles c'est une
reconstruction totale qui s'engage pour
le cirano il passera de 8 à 12 salles 10
seront accessibles pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite
un investissement important c'est un
investissement de l'ordre de 9 millions
d'euros
c'est donc un investissement stratégique
parce qu'il s'inscrit dans cette logique
de maillage et de proximité
nous pensons que aujourd'hui les gens
aux besoins d'accessibilité de proximité
et de lieux très qualitatif le cyrano
retrouvera son entrée historique celle
de l'époque des concerts après les
travaux l'accès se fera de nouveau par
la rue rameau on aime cette idée de
cinéma de quartier parce que c'est son
os et son identité
moi ce que j'aime c'est quand on a des
parents qui viennent avec leurs enfants
et que les parents disent c'est mon
cinéma c'est là où je viens viens depuis
que je suis tout petit quand j'ai des
réalisateurs comme eric toledano comme
guillaume canet qui me disent cinéma ce
je viens là depuis tout petit
l'ouverture au public du nouveau cyrano
est prévue pour fin 2020